bonjour à tous depuis les années 70
saint quentin en yvelines a de tout
temps considéré la problématique des
transports comme l'un des enjeux majeurs
du développement de son territoire
d'ailleurs l'agglomération dispose du
premier réseau de bus franciliens juste
après celui de la ratp dans les années à
venir l'offre de transport devrait
considérablement s'améliorer sur saint
quentin en yvelines avec par exemple
l'arrivée de la ligne 18 ou bien encore
d'autolib
alors comment tout cela va-t-il se
passer quelle est l'offre actuelle de
transport sur saint quentin en yvelines
on en parle dans votre ski mag
et
la question des transports et de la
mobilité fait véritablement partie de
l'adn de saint quentin en yvelines dans
les années 70 lorsque les premiers
quartiers sortir de terre ce fut de part
et d'autre de deux grands axes de
communication véritable colonne
vertébrale de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la nationale 10 et évidemment la voie
ferrée que l'on voit derrière moi
depuis les voies de communication se
sont multipliées sur saint quentin en
yvelines
la communauté d'agglomération compte
bien poursuivre et améliorer l'offre de
transport vers et depuis son territoire
et même intra muros indispensable
puisque elle ambitionne de faire partie
de la silicon valley à la française en
elle était la première collectivités
franciliennes approuvé son plan local de
déplacement
saint quentin en yvelines est le
deuxième pôle de développement
économique après la défense et par
conséquent regroupe un grand nombre
d'entreprises également de logements
nous avons des axes routiers qui sont
quand même très saturé donc l'offre de
transport est essentielle à la
continuité de ce développement
économique est recruté du territoire
aujourd'hui saint quentin en yvelines
compte sept gares réparties sur tout son
territoire la gare de montigny le
bretonneux
inauguré en 1975 au moment de la
création de la ville nouvelle dont elle
porte le nom
la gare a été entièrement rénové pour
devenir un pôle multimodal ravalement de
façade plus de commerces nouvelle gare
routière des équipements indispensables
pour accueillir soixante dix mille
personnes par jour depuis le 1er janvier
trois nouvelles gares ont rejoint le
périmètre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
plaisir grignon plaisir les clés et
villepreux les clés cette dernière a
fait l'objet d'une rénovation entre 2009
et 2010 afin notamment de faciliter
l'accès aux personnes handicapées
les gars de coignières trabet la
verrière sont les plus anciennes du
territoire en terme de fréquentation
la verrière et la deuxième guerre de
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise après
celle de montigny le bretonneux
pas moins de vingt minutes
ja jeunes quotidien le réaménagement de
la gare de la verrière et de ses abords
fait partie des grands projets de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines début 2017 les
travaux de doublement du pont guy
schuller qui est derrière moi devrait
commencer en fait ce doublement
permettra de fluidifier le trafic entre
le centre-ville de maurepas qu'on voit
là bas au loin et la gare de la verrière
alors c'est un projet important pour le
territoire mais aussi pour les mort
passe bien parce qu'il faut le savoir
ici par jour c'est vingt mille véhicules
vingt mille véhicules et tous les matins
à maurepas en semaine ce sont des
bouchons sur l'entrée de ville de mort
pas jusque à la gare de la verrière donc
un engorgement maximum
et pour comprendre le calvaire enduré
par de nombreux automobilistes je vous
propose une petite expérience donc là je
pars du centre-ville de maurepas et mon
objectif c'est de rejoindre la rédaction
à guyancourt en passant par la rn10 donc
pour ça je vais devoir franchir le pont
guy schuller et voyez un jet à peine
fait quelques mètres que déjà ça coince
j'ai encore aujourd'hui je suis plutôt
chanceux parce que j'aurais pu me
retrouver bloqué dès le rond point
d'entrée de ville 1 ça arrive très
régulièrement
donc maintenant il me reste plus qu'à
prendre mon mal en patience
là on arrive à proximité du fameux
passage piéton qui créent
en général les embouteillages ça fait
plus de dix ans que l'agglomération de
saint quentin et sur le projet qui voit
enfin le jour puisque les travaux ont
commencé l'année prochaine début 2017
pour 26 mois
vingt-six mois de travaux c'est n'est
pas rien il est vraiment le pont à
doubler des aménagements de voirie a
créé même en termes qualitatifs ça va
tout changer puisque là derrière moi
nous avons quand même un urbanisme
vieillissant qui a plus de 40 ans donc
là c'est vraiment une opportunité aussi
pour améliorer le cadre de vie
des habitants alors concrètement qu'y
at-il dans ce projet qui coûtera environ
12 millions d'euros
il comprend notamment une voie dédiée à
l'intégration urbaine du transport en
commun en site propre qui reliera à
terme les guerres de trappes et de là
derrière la sécurisation du
franchissement de la rn 10 pour les
piétons et les cyclistes et une nouvelle
bois qui permettra aux automobilistes de
rejoindre la gare et l'actuel parking de
stationnement
vous l'avez compris dans les années à
venir la gare de la verrière est amené à
devenir un véritable pôle multimodal
mais plus largement c'est l'ensemble de
ce quartier qui va se transformer dans
le cadre du projet urbain la verrière
gare bécane
le carrefour de la madone deviendra un
giratoire est un pôle de développement
économique verra le jour transformant
ainsi profondément le visage de la
commune
les étudiants les travailleurs et même
les vacanciers qui transitent par les
sept gares de saint quentin en yvelines
bénéficie pour l'instant deux trois
lignes
plusieurs projets ferroviaires devraient
voir le jour dans les prochaines années
le stif envisage par exemple le
prolongement du rer c jusqu'à coignières
par ailleurs la tangentielle ouest
reliera en 2010 9 hr à saint-cyr-l'ecole
facilitant ainsi les trajets domicile
travail vers le bassin d'emploi de saint
quentin en yvelines
enfin projet très attendu une nouvelle
ligne verra le jour d'ici 2024
la ligne 18 du grand paris express qui
reliera versailles chantiers à orly à
saint quentin en yvelines
il est prévu de construire une nouvelle
gare dans le quartier de villas roi à
guyancourt saint quentin est
ce projet primordial pour le territoire
saint-quentin accueille des chercheurs
de niveau mondial avec le développement
de saclay de l'université de pau de
recherche l'opération d'intérêt national
il est il est plus qu'une évidence que
la ligne 18 est indispensable pour
permettre entre autres l'accès via les
aéroports que ce soir lit ou roissy 2
voilà de ses chercheurs pour venir
justement se rendre sur sur le post le
plateau de saclay y contribuer et donc
développement économique
la notoriété du territoire
saint quentin en yvelines c'est
également un formidable réseau de bus
baptisé ce qui lui sort il existe depuis
il s'agit du premier réseau de bus en
ile de france juste après celui de la
ratp
aujourd'hui il compte 39 lignes qui
desservent presque l'intégralité de la
communauté d'agglomération mais ça
devrait prochainement changer puisque
vous le savez saint-quentin-en-yvelines
compte désormais douze communes et donc
le réseau devrait évoluer en prenant en
compte les nouvelles frontières de la
communauté d'agglomération il s'est
avéré que le la convention qui liait le
calbut c ur toul avec la casquette avec
les territoires ' ristori qu est caduc à
la fin de cette année donc plutôt que de
l'art conso que reconduire technique
mais avec les thaï power historique que
nous avons souhaité l'élargir ou aux
territoires entre ans de façon à ce que
les cinq communes puissent aussi
bénéficier d'un réseau bus digne de ce
nom on veut profiter de cette dynamique
pour justement remettre à plat le réseau
et avoir des bus des lignes de bus qui
soient plus cohérentes qui sont plus
fréquentes ou également parce que plus
abuse plus les gens effectivement vont
utiliser ce mode de déplacement et donc
un appel d'offres est lancé pour un
appel à projets pour un diagnostic de
l'existant et une refonte de l'ensemble
du réseau avec la prise en compte de
tout le nouveau territoire
mais ce n'est pas là le seul changement
la gestion de vos trajets devrait être
prochainement facile
grâce à la modernisation du système des
aides à l'exploitation et d'information
des voyageurs
or ça coûtera 3 millions d'euros de
travaux des travaux nécessaires puisque
l'ancien système date d'il ya douze ans
et que depuis eh bien le réseau s'est
considérablement développé ce système à
deux fonctions principales
la première c'est de géolocaliser les
véhicules sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines pour permettre aux
agents d'encadrement de réguler les
lignes d'autobus les passages en de
gérer les incidents sur ligne et la
deuxième fonction principale c'est
d'informer les clients
nous allons déployer avec l'aide de la
communauté d'agglomération 158 bornes
disséminées sur l'ensemble du territoire
et 7 ces bornes d'information
permettront
aux clients de connaître les deux
prochains passage des autobus de
connaître bien sûr leurs et ils pourront
avoir des messages à titres commerciaux
ou au niveau des problématiques
d'exploitation du réseau
donc en plus de l'information en temps
réel nous mettrons en place d'ici l'été
une information via des cuirs code qui
seront apposées sur les abribus et puis
une application via les smartphones
la modernisation du système des dalles
exploitation et d'information des
voyageurs se fera cet été
pas d'inquiétude cela n'aura aucune
incidence sur vos trajets tout à l'heure
je vous parlais du futur transport en
commun en site propre qui reliera les
gars de trappes et de la verrière
mais savez vous ce qu'est un transport
en commun en site propre
on l'appelle également tcsp il s'agit en
fait d'un moyen de transport qui utilise
une voix qui lui est dédié c'est par
exemple le cas de la ligne de bus 91 06
qui part de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines et qui va jusqu'à magny les
hameaux
en fait ce type de services s'inscrit
pleinement dans une démarche globale en
faveur des énergies propres sur saint
quentin en yvelines et bien par exemple
beaucoup
pistes cyclables et prochainement on
devrait voir arriver
accrochez vous bien autolib et oui
autolib débarque à saint quentin en
yvelines
le projet suit son cours en partenariat
avec le syndicat mixte et bolloré des
stations sont prévues donc dans les
différentes villes de l'intercommunalité
avec alors c'est une station par tranche
de 8000 habitants
le projet a été présenté aux communes
les services différentes services
techniques des villes se sont réunis et
travaille actuellement sur les
emplacements pour proposer les bornes
électriques et puis donc vous pourrait
se situer
c'est voilà ces véhicules sommes très
heureux de pouvoir accueillir ce projet
on espère fin d'année début de l'année
prochaine
chaque station comportera six véhicules
le projet est actuellement en cours de
concertation avec les maires concernés
les transports sont véritablement
vecteur d'attractivité pour tout
territoire qui tend à se développer
comme saint quentin en yvelines
ils rendent service aux habitants attire
les entreprises
d'ailleurs ce détail n'a pas échappé à
valérie pécresse qui s'exprimait
récemment lors de la soirée des
entrepreneurs de saint quentin en
yvelines
elle a réaffirmé l'engagement de la
région en faveur de la mobilité en
citant notamment l'exemple d'un projet
très attendu à saint quentin en yvelines
la région ile de france sous la pression
des verts a refusé d'investir dans les
routes depuis des années nous habitons
la grande couronne mais il un grand
nombre d'entre vous la guette aussi il
travaille qu'il y en prend
malheureusement trop souvent la voiture
parce qu'on n'a pas d'autre choix et on
se retrouve bloqué pendant des heures
d'embouteillages donc la vérité c'est
que moi je n'aurai pas de table et comme
je n'ai pas de tabou il ya on va
reprendre les investissements routiers
je sais que dans l'île il ya un sujet
c'est l'enfouissement de la nationale 10
qui permettrait de fluidifier cette
nationale c'est un sujet que donc je
discute avec le président du conseil
départemental mais j'ai fait adopter un
amendement à la loi sur les compétences
des régions
d'ailleurs le président d'aquitaine
poitou charentes nous à monsieur rousset
il ya quelques il ya quelques mois qui
disait que la région pouvait investir
dans des routes d'intérêt régional ok à
nous de définir quelles sont les routes
d'intérêt régional sur lesquels qu'il
faut investir pour les purifier
et voilà ce qui m'agace c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui mais on se retrouve très
vite pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là en train en bus en voiture en
auto lib ou en vélo
portez vous bien ciao bye